lange hat der bundeskanzler dafür
gebraucht seine haltung zu ändern über
wochen viel olaf scholz in sachen
russland er dadurch auf dass er seine
standardformel zur nord stream 2 das sei
ein rein privatwirtschaftliches vorhaben
strich vortrug davon musste er sich
diese woche verabschieden jetzt soll
alles auf den tisch auch die pipeline
dazu gehört eben auch dass klar ist dass
das hohe kosten haben wird und das alles
das zu diskutieren ist wenn es zu einer
militärischen intervention gegen die
ukraine kommt wo scholz lange gezögert
hat haben zwei ehemalige spd-vorsitzende
klartext geredet und damit offenbart wie
gespalten die parteien der russland
frage ist wenn man diplomatisch erfolg
haben will muss man das weiß ich fällt
uns schwer erst mal sagen ja eure
sicherheitsbedürfnisse eure
sicherheitsbedenken sind anzuerkennen
beziehungsweise wir werden mit ihnen
umgehen das haben wir 30 jahre lang
nicht gemacht obwohl die russen nicht
erst seit heute darüber reden der preis
für krieg in europa der muss klar sein
ich bin wie sie wissen jemand der immer
für entspannung mit russland gewesen ist
ich bin auch immer ein vertreter von
nord stream gewesen aber bei krieg ist
sozusagen jede fahndungs bereitschaft zu
ende und das müssen die russen wissen
dass krieg mittlerweile bestandteil der
russischen politik geworden ist davon
ist ein teil der genossen überzeugt
neben gesprächen und verhandlungen
wollen sie auch mit sanktionen drohen
sie wollen dialog fordern aber auch wer
bereitschaft wenn man sich die konkrete
bedrohungslage anschaut und das könnte
ja gegebenenfalls zu einem krieg führen
und wir uns dezidiert aus guten gründen
entschlossen haben als nato als
europäische gemeinschaft nicht
militärisch zu intervenieren
dann müssen wir alle anderen
bestandteile unseres diplomatischen
instrumenten kastens nutzen und dazu
gehören dann im falle des falles auch
sanktionen die entstehungsgeschichte von
nord stream 2 ist eng mit der spd
verbunden
der aufsichtsratschef der
betreibergesellschaft der gaspipeline
heißt gerhard schröder und schon ist man
bei den anderen genossen für die
wirtschafts verträge mit russland auch
immer ein bisschen entspannungs politik
sind wandel durch handel das drohen mit
sanktionen zählt bei ihnen schon als
überflüssiges säbelrasseln
wenn ich forderungen lese dass jeder
meint aus seinem polstersesseln heraus
aktions forderung erheben zu können oder
aber über waffenlieferungen redet dann
trägt das nicht dazu bei dass am ende
die diplomatie erfolg hat und ich glaube
dass es gemeinsame interessen gibt die
liegen im bereich der wissenschaft die
liegen im bereich der wirtschaft die
liege im bereich von jugendaustausch
papas angelegenheit bei vielen anderen
dingen über die momentan keiner redet
weil die stiftung vergeben weil die
stimmung vergiftet es die beiden spd
vorsitzenden hielten sich lange zurück
und haben jetzt das neue wording von
olaf scholz übernommen die zerrissenheit
in ihrer partei allerdings ignorieren
sie weiter die spd ist ja nicht
gespalten bei diesem thema die spd ist
sehr klar bei den prinzipien die ich
gesagt habe wir nehmen die bedrohung
sehr ernst haben wir sind auch klar und
unmissverständlich in der konsequenz die
eine militärische eskalation seitens
russland hätte alles kommt auf den tisch
auch nord stream 2 darauf haben sie sich
also geeinigt in der führung der spd
über die daraus resultierenden
konsequenzen aber macht der
fraktionsvorsitzende aufmerksam und
konterkariert damit irgendwie den
kanzler ich mag mir gar nicht ausmalen
was passieren wird in zukunft was das
für die wirtschaftlichen beziehungen
bedeutet aber letztlich eben auch für
die energieversorgung insgesamt in einer
schweren außenpolitischen krise biete
die spd kein wirklich beschlossenes bild
für eine kanzlerpartei ist das fatal